in tonight's democracy 2020 report Joe
Biden is up in most national polls with
some of the crowds in the first primary
state do not seem to be happy with all
of his answers correspondent Ellison
barber reports tonight from New
Hampshire where Biden once again was
forced to clarify his remarks on how he
would react to a potential congressional
subpoena today former Vice President Joe
Biden sat down with an editorial board
in Portsmouth and for the fourth time in
as many days tried to clarify what he
meant when he told the Des Moines
Register he would not comply if he was
subpoenaed to testify in the Senate
impeachment trial seven weeks to go
recent polls show New Hampshire is still
up for grabs
mayor budda judge Biden and senator
Bernie Sanders are all within three
points of each other Sanders who
suffered a heart attack
earlier this year got a bill of good
health from Congress's attending
physician and according to the Sanders
campaign the senator's personal
cardiologist says at this point he is
confident Sanders has the mental and
physical stamina to fully undertake the
rigors of the presidency Budda judge is
one of two remaining 20/20 candidates
who served in the military right now the
mayor who deployed to Afghanistan is
going after the former vice president
for his vote on the war in Iraq while he
was still in the Senate this is an
example of why years in Washington is
not always the same thing as judgment he
supported the worst foreign policy
decision made by the United States in my
lifetime and Biden is swinging back God
I respected the fact his service and his
wounds to go I'm the guy that pointed
out repeatedly that we should not be
going into Afghanistan but as buddha'
judge attacked Biden's record in the
Senate protesters at a town hall made it
more personal let her go let her go I'd
encountered that he's done something
president Trump refuses to do released
over 20 years of his tax returns the
next fundraising deadline is tomorrow
senator Elizabeth Warren is slipping in
the polls here in New Hampshire she sent
a letter to supporters saying that they
are aiming to raise twenty million
dollars this quarter and they are not
there yet it's a big number but it is 20
percent less than what she raised last
quarter Mike Ellison thanks a lot